depuis ses 18 ans patricia dans son sang
régulièrement en tant que femme elle
peut le faire tous les quatre mois
vous pouvez combien j'ai pas demandés
480 habitants
c'est une question de solidarité aussi
je pense
je me disais un jour j'en ai besoin je
serais bien content d'avoir du sang
logiquement qu'il faut donner dès ce
mardi après-midi ils étaient nombreux à
venir à la collecte mobile au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
enregistrement une visite médicale pour
s'assurer de ne pas avoir de contre
indications et l'on accède aux
prélèvements je pense que ce je trouve
que c'est un geste citoyen guitare qui
est important une dizaine de minutes de
prélèvement avant le passage à la
collation primordial pour une bonne
réhydratation suis arrivé à 14 heures je
pense qu'il doit pas être trois heures
et ce quasiment films ont donc ça prend
une petite heure au plus avec les
vacances scolaires l'épidémie de grippe
et les mobilisations du samedi
l'établissement français de sang est en
manque de dons par exemple les vacances
en avril et mai avec les ponts sont des
moments difficiles donc on doit déjà
anticipé mais naturellement ses besoins
lent les événements ont besoin de 1700
donc par jour prochaine collecte dans
l'agglomération le samedi 23 mars à
villepreux